looks like she came here because it's a
bit of a cabin atmosphere up 13 to 9
laughter he's doing a smart thing for
syntheses bacon porzingis feel good
dodge his cabin under the basket lays it
up place it in everybody can't be a
stuffed bird everybody can't shoot like
klay Thompson and I think sometimes guys
get caught up into that
not about him on a basketball field
fortunate to have a match for sure
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of basketball fans with the
dungeons to the basket you'll get it and
one the Mavs very very good Luke is tied
with James Harden for the post of the
league not just gets a porzingis screen
steps back or Zynga screen Luca behind
the back of the basket
the advantage
23 watch this he's able to split right
there to piston defenders and get to the
basket so clever and again to see with
this and they do stop the Pistons in the
paint or zingers to the man his quick
dunk to the wing menisci we'll take a
timeout struggling so they'd be about to
get off the snide sometimes